you
so big news this morning as tech giant
Apple is unveiling a redesigned store
this morning outside the world's tallest
building in Dubai the company is also
announcing new educational sessions that
will launch next month in all its stores
called today at Apple the updates are
the work of a team led by Apple's
highest ranking female executive Angela
Erin's became Apple's senior vice
president of retail in 2014 after
working as CEO Burberry she has overseen
the stores most significant redesign
since they opened around 15 years ago
Apple CEO Tim Cook calls are wicked
smart and the 56 year old took us inside
Apple's updated stores in New York in a
rare TV interview you'll see only on CBS
this morning she explains how the
world's most valuable company sees the
future of retail I was thinking about
this because this is the first big
redesign in 15 years and it was Steve
Jobs and Ron Johnson who did the first
design of the Apple stores did that
weigh on you oh my gosh
following in Steve Jobs footsteps here
you know I think that anything you do at
Apple you feel a tremendous onus you
want to carry on the legacy of what it
meant
the main objective our sole is our
people and our job is to enrich their
lives change the world and so I think
that's the bigger pressure you put on
yourself
this is our store it was in 2001 that
the world got its first look inside an
Apple store we're so excited about this
but now the look and the feel of the
stores is changing
thanks to Angela Erin's we have a screen
like this in a hundred stores senior
vice president of Apple Retail so how
will we see the stores change um you
know probably the simplest way to
describe it because everything Apple has
to be simple the way that that we kind
of talk about it inside we say this is
the largest product that Apple produces
so if you think of it the hardware which
is the architecture of the store the
software is what happens in the store
and how we basically turn on Apple music
in the app store so we started with the
hardware in 100 of its biggest stores
like this Sam Francis
go flagship apples hardware update means
new screens and spaces for meetings and
classes the Genius Bar now lined with
trees becomes the genius Grove and
there's a more dimensional take on the
genius
new staffers specialized in music and
photography called creative prose is the
idea that the store will have all of
these listed classes teachers
experiences that will be publicly posted
that will draw more and more people in
absolutely so we call the software of
the store that we're launching the end
of May we call that today at Apple that
software will roll out across apples
nearly 500 stores many of which will be
changed literally overnight Aaron's
calls it an effort to create town
squares where customers engage with
their devices and their communities a
lot of the big online guys have said
they're opening stores Amazon is
investing in stores
Google's investing in stores Starbucks
figured it out yet oh being a gathering
place for right meet me at Starbucks and
you know and I've told the teams I'll
know we've done a really really great
job if the next generation of Gen Z says
meet me an apple did you see what's
going on at Apple today does that apply
to Android and Samsung users too
absolutely absolutely and we have an
incredible trade up program that they
yeah Apple isn't exactly strapped for
cash having set a revenue record of
almost 80 billion dollars this fiscal
year but Aaron's insists the in-store
experience isn't cheapened just because
there are products for sale there's a
little bit of a harder question but I
know you've thought so much about this
can you foster a sense of community at
the same time having a commercial
objective yeah I thought a lot about it
and and I would argue it's kind of what
Apple's always done anyway I think we've
always been this energy hub if you will
we're just empowering the teams to take
it so much further sales of iPhones and
Mac computers have been strong in 2017
but well there was a
a bit of a dip in 2016 and some people
speculated well apples at the end of its
product line and the store redesign is
just window dressing how do you respond
to that
yeah I'd respond they probably don't
really know the company that well it's a
you know each of the businesses that
Apple has are so big
Tim talks a lot during the earnings
calls on the service business and how
rapidly that's growing and you know and
that's the part really we had never been
able to unlock in detail before it was
at Burberry that Aaron's first merged
retail with online shopping tripling
companies stock and prompting Tim Cook
to call London from Cupertino I told Tim
this as we were interviewing I said I am
not a techie like wrong person you know
and and he he and a very politely said I
think we have a lot of those and so why
did he want you if you're not a techie I
think when it came down to honestly
because the teams are so big and so
global I think that a lot of it had to
do with leadership I read that part of
the reason that he hired you was because
of your ability to motivate people how
do you motivate people you don't
overthink it right do unto others
I mean you connect with them and you
care and you and you do what you say
you're gonna do I mean it's not rocket
science
Aaron says it's her Midwestern
upbringing as one of six children raised
in new Palestine Indiana that keeps her
humble even as she's become one of the
highest-paid executives at Apple and in
the country Steve Jobs was famously
empathetic I've heard you say empathy is
one of the greatest creators of energy
what role has it played in your success
I mean again I think huge and my dad
used to always say I can teach you
anything but I can't teach you to feel I
can't teach you to care and I think when
you're empathetic you're putting
yourself in somebody else's shoes it's
not about you there's 7 billion people
on the planet it's not about you I think
that when you're empathetic to someone
they open up to you right they don't get
defensive and when they open up you're
both open and then you can dream and you
can
you know come up with incredible things
together and it unlocks a lot of things
think about that empathy is one of the
greatest creators of energy great words
to govern by to manage by to live by
yeah emotional intelligence yeah also
the retail piece of that is totally
fascinating as as brick-and-mortar loses
ground to online retailers online and
dot-com retailers you're looking at
brick and mortar that Apple story is
fascinating you did a big piece on Apple
two big pieces for first 60 minutes you
know how much were you Tim Cook doctor
loved her really went over there to
seduce her to bring her back to
California yeah to get her to lead River
I thought she was the best retail brain
out there yeah and now we're seeing it
in fruition
yes I can see more of our interview with
Angela Erin's including why she has
never taken any job for the money on our
website CBS this morning calm